ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'une tonne
de métal est extraite de la loire
surtout quand c'est une bombe une bombe
de la seconde guerre mondiale planté
dans le sable de saint cyr sur loire
depuis près de 80 ans une fois les
riverains mise à l'abri les démineurs
ont pu neutraliser l'engin explosif leur
reportage de romain delville à l'heure
où la loire offre ses plus belles lueur
commence le travail des démineurs il est
8 heures la première des cinq phases de
déminage commence l'examen et la
préparation de la bombe d'une tonne
datant de la deuxième guerre mondiale à
partir de 9h les rues de la zone de
sécurité la rd 952 en bord de fleuve
sont coupées à la circulation
toutes les habitations doivent être
évacués
ça concerne environ 1000 personnes et on
a distribué des dépliants à l'ensemble
des riverains de la zone l'invitant à
quitter les lieux et puis on a organisé
aussi l'évacuation des personnes les
plus sensibles je pense par exemple
10 danses de personnes handicapées ou
des personnes hospitalisées à domicile à
9h30 commence le déminage la
neutralisation des dispositif d'amorçage
à l'abri des regards pendant ce temps la
croix-rouge gère l'accueil des personnes
pour la plupart âgées au sein de
l'ancienne mairie de saint cyr ici on
lit où on discute c'est à dire qu'on
nous amener l'eau scrabble avec les
délais les revues pour nous occuper un
petit peu mais on est très occupé avec
mes petits voisins à discuter de choses
et d'autres ont fait connaissance c'est
ça qui est fabuleux c'est qu'on fait
connaissance dans ce genre de choses
étudiante en psychologie emma est venu
avec ses animaux elle habitait des
maisons blanches et n'a pas de solution
de relogement temporaire la seule
personne chez qui je peux aller valait
aussi sur les quais donc va elle aussi
être évacués et puis ma famille est dans
le loiret
11 heures les nouvelles sont bonnes du
côté de la bombe et les sorties hors de
l'eau c'est la phase 4 puis intervient
la dernière phase la destruction du
dispositif d'amorçage sur la petite île
voisine
l'opération s'est parfaitement déroulé
dans le sens où toutes les phases ont
été respectées dans ce qui avait été
prévu ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
on est quelques petits déboires
mécaniques mais dans l'ensemble on a
réussi à
oeuvrer dans l'est dans les tanks
étaient impartis 13 heures l'opération a
été plus rapide que prévu la bombe
américaine et escorté jusqu'à
l'autoroute
soixante dix huit ans après son largage
elle va finir sa vie au centre de
déminage de laon dans l'aisne